President Lincoln also said at a time
America is the last test of Uncle hey
would you repeat it now and would you
repeat it Lincoln spoke of the United
States is the last best hope on earth
because the United States was the last
and only and first successful democratic
republic in the world europe in his time
in Lincoln's time was a continent in
which Democratic revolutions had been
suppressed after the springtime of
nations in the revolutions of 1848 the
United States stood alone and then the
Civil War presented a great test and if
the United States were to succeed it
would be the last best hope as the
example of liberalism to the rest of the
world it was not an accident that it was
the gift of the French people to the
United States of the Statue of Liberty
that now stands in New York Harbor which
is a statue that was given to represent
the victory in the Civil War that statue
holds the declaration of independence in
one arm in which proclaims that all men
are created equal and at its feet are
the broken chains of slavery also
significantly and symbolically the
Statue of Liberty does not face towards
the United States but towards Europe
even in the 19th century and now the
United States also radiates out to the
to the rest of the world
it's the most important thing about
being the last best hope is to be an
example and that means that the United
States must reform its own democracy and
that this is an internal process and if
it is to be the last best hope it
requires ourselves to create the
American example ourselves